est-ce que tu regrettes les années tf1
ou 7 manque
ce qui était fou avec la méthode c'était
d'arriver et de et de se dire qu'on
allait écrire une page blanche et faire
trois heures d'émission en se disant à
l'adaptateur génial avec les trucs que
tu as bien connu c'est à dire quand tu
as fait une grosse audience la semaine
d'avant et que tu as fait 45 les gâteaux
disent bravo mais dans leurs yeux il ya
écrit bon cette semaine ont fait pas
moins docta tu dois déconner avec une
certaine pression non en fait je n'ai
pas de regrets parce que je trouve qu'il
ya des choses qu'il faut faire à un
moment et si j'avais pas si facile ça ne
s'était pas arrêtée ce n'était pas mon
choix la fin de la méthode ça s'était
pas arrêté aurait pas eu derrière les
tours de manège la radio le one man
peut-être les réseaux sociaux et tout
donc au final non parce que c'était un
vrai qu'ils font n'a fermé on a fermé la
page et c'était une grosse angoisse
quand même parce que derrière la halle à
la décontraction et l'amusement quand
arrivait que tu enchaînes
un cyril un une star américaine un
stallone qui te dit j'ai quinze minutes
un train est tu dis oui mais ça fait
déjà trois minutes que tu essaies d'en
vau de mettre ton oreillettes et bada
trop tard il reste 13 minutes et que tu
vois tu enchaînes sata tutelle voilà il
fallait faire là il fallait assurer les
parties et c'est c'était très stressant
à l'arrivée au final on s'est aimés
c'est vraiment une émission voilà je te
dis cela c'est ainsi qu'un rendez-vous à
la plus des rendez-vous comme ça non
mais c'est vrai et en évoquant mhi toi
et c'est un truc c'est un truc de fou et
je me rappelle des scores que faisait
parce que oui et moi on ne le dit
j'étais très très proche de toi même à
l'époque on est toujours les matches
mais c'est vrai que j'étais très proche
de jeunes et souvent de voir au bureau
on regardait même autres apple on avait
souvent les audiences le matin le
vendredi matin parce que tu avais est à
la radio le matin mais ça arrive congrès
les audiences ensemble souvent et il me
disait 40
40 49 ménagères tard loubat c'était
assez fiable c'est une petite angoisse
vers 9h 9h15 mis ce qu'il fallait être
fallait faire le con à la radio ouais et
puis tu avais un mec qui te connais tu
parle à l'oreille faisait 42 karman est
reportée frais et quand il disait ça a
été bien j'aimerais qu'on s'est
constitué
c'est vrai parce que moi j'étais là bas
tous les vendredis matins quand je ris
pas compte de sa mère
non mais c'est vrai que c'était quand
même le solde actuel invités ça n'a
jamais su pourquoi c'est pas de promo un
spectacle des monstres comme je les aime
jouer mais s'il était acquis s'il est
bien
qu'il ait fait une équipe assez bien lui
qui passe non mais c'est vrai que
j'étais petit j'étais là j'étais là
quand j'étais dans le vrai même dans le
public avait fait un truc de la mettrais
et réjouir on a passé moi c'est rcd
moment je le dis vraiment je me suis
régalé je me souviens d'un truc qu'on
avait fait à la radio on avait un studio
tout neufs qu'ils avaient refait les
mecs nous avait dit attention le studio
enough j'ai plus été à fun monsieur
d'rtl j'aimerais souhaiter était
vraiment neuf donc il était et on
commence on fait un truc avec du
chocolat il y avait tenu des
jardins de la mairie vers vous et oui
j'étais créé un mois
et syrie évidemment on commence à s'en
mettre partout je commence à voir des
traces de doigts
je ne voyais plus que ça il y avait la
pauvre ans jamie qui était arrivé comme
x apple ferry cheetah il lui a couru
après jeu
en 2d dit totalement recouvert félix
la cour a couru cornell a commencé à
avoir peur et on a tout nettoyé pendant
trente-huit d'arcade